do you know where i could find a great
job who knew that this jesse line would
one day be relatable to so many members
of the series cast
jessie was a huge hit for the disney
channel for almost five years
and with its unique new york city vibes
and hilarious cast
it's really no surprise it was one of
the network's longest running shows
however the jesse actors haven't seen
much success outside of their disney
bubble
could this be part of the infamous
disney curse or could it be that growing
up in the spotlight was just too much
for these actors to handle
wow is that a diamond ring or disco ball
it's time to take a look at why exactly
this cast of seemingly talented young
adults
are majorly struggling when it comes to
landing gigs
i didn't come all the way from fort hood
in texas to be a babysitter
the leading lady herself debbie ryan has
even struggled to make a name for
herself
outside of the disney channel while she
hasn't completely disappeared
let's just say she hasn't exactly made
it big like fellow disney stars demi
lovato and miley cyrus
mainly spending her time working on
short films and guest appearances
she did have the opportunity to break
out of her disney persona with her
netflix series
insatiable while a netflix series seems
like a positive step in
anyone's career insatiable just wasn't
it
the show and debbie received major
backlash when it came to how the series
dealt with eating disorders and body
dysmorphia
even before it aired after two short
problematic seasons it was cancelled
so why exactly is hollywood refusing to
cast debbie
well in a 2017 interview the actress
opened up about life after jessie
and how opportunities really depended on
how casting agents saw her
the best part in the years since we
ended jessie has been being able to walk
through a couple doors that have been
open
and then bang down some that were closed
because people saw me with mouse ears
there's no doubt that disney stars have
always been held to a different standard
than other rising stars
just take a look at past child stars
like lindsay lohan and miley cyrus that
have been labeled
good girls gone wrong by the industry
there must have been a lot of pressure
on debbie to have hollywood not place
her in that category
good news it turns out i mostly think
very highly of you
coming of age on not one but two hit
disney shows
definitely couldn't have been easy for
peyton list while the now 22 year old
had a very successful start as a child
star
things have almost grounded to a halt
for this actress
after jessie payton did get to share her
talents on the spin-off series bunked
but she's yet to make waves beyond the
walls of disney studios
she of course left disney on her own
terms before bunked even ended
explaining that everyone grows up and
starts new projects
and that she is grateful to her fans who
have grown alongside her
while she also mentioned that she hoped
her fans would follow her on new
adventures
she has yet to report any huge
breakthroughs that will get her foot
in the door of hollywood but the
explanation for her lack of work is
actually a happy one like many disney
stars payton recently admitted that
she's focusing her efforts on building
her music career
she recently released her single liar
liar and says that delving into her
music roots
is more rewarding than acting because
she gets to bear her soul
while peyton may have left the world of
disney willingly she still
isn't clear from the scrutiny that comes
along with being a star on the channel
there's something so pure about the
disney image that i think people like
seeing the opposite happen
she told instyle magazine and went on to
also explain that she wonders how long
it'll be before the press stops calling
her out for being a disney star when she
does something
even a tad scandalous how could she be
mean to you you're so adorable
i know right skye jackson also known as
the little bundle of sass that was zuri
ross
like her co-star peyton skye also
appeared on the jessie spin-off series
bunked
until she also decided to leave disney
in 2018.
since her bunked series she has starred
in plenty of short films and has even
lent her voice to the animated marvel
rising
chasing ghost's glory but she's yet to
reach the caliber of stardom she was
living during her time on jessie
like payton this young actress has also
been pursuing side hustles
she wrote and published her own book
back in 2019
called reach for the sky how to inspire
empower
and clap back while the memoir was no
doubt filled with her intense experience
growing up in the spotlight
it never became a bestseller and
actually received pretty negative
reviews
despite all that skye still has her eyes
on the prize she's admitted that she has
hopes of one day starring in her very
own horror film
and dreams of getting the opportunity to
be featured on her favorite series
stranger things
we're rooting for you skye
howdy man karen braar also known as ravi
ross and his sidekick
mrs kipling were definitely part of the
heart of jesse
and it may have something to do with how
grounded karen is in real life
for him life after jesse also involved
bunk like sky and peyton
but he also went on to land a role in
the disney plus film star girl
alongside grace vanderwaal outside of
disney he's yet to really dive into the
world of a-listers
but when you take a look at what karen
stands for it's not really a surprise
to him he admits he never went into the
world of showbiz saying
i want to be in the lights and fame
instead of looking at acting as a way to
be famous
he looks at it as something he loves
maybe he's just waiting for that perfect
roll
sorry some things i just like to keep
for myself tenzig norgay trainer took it
a step further than just starring on a
disney series
after his time on jesse wrapped he went
on to work on the equally popular show
liv and maddie but those aren't the only
deals he signed with disney
he also landed the lead voice role of
jyn in the disney animated film
abominable
the film never reached the heights of
films like frozen and moana which means
tenzing never went on to become a
household name at least not yet
tenzing also hasn't been shy about his
future plans although he does want to
continue acting
school is also in the books for him in
an interview with record online
he says he wants to finish his senior
year and then send out college
applications
and go on auditions he also plans on
staying in southern california so that
he can do both
we definitely haven't seen the last of
him i suggest you give me a name
i can't tell you i'm sworn to secret
spectrum
[Applause]
chris gallia also known as our favorite
bell boy
okay maybe he's second favorite after
zach and cody's iconic esteban
since his time on jesse he's moved on to
other projects but nothing has been the
hit that every actor dreams of landing
one day
if you've really been missing him you
can catch him in his film dead trigger
besides that chris gallia just seems to
be really living the life
if you check out his instagram you'll
see he's been passing the days away
traveling the world with his girlfriend
and taking the most adorable pictures
not to mention he spends a lot of time
gaming on twitch with his thousands of
subscribers
no children in my way
as much as we all love kevin chamberlin
his ride through hollywood has been
anything but easy
he was a favorite character on jessie
but it seems like he's spent his career
being stereotyped as the funny
supporting character
his work since jesse just proves it even
more after the series came to a close in
2015
he did return for a cameo and bunked but
also guest starred in shows like modern
family
grace and frankie and series of
unfortunate events
those shows are huge but kevin has never
gotten the recognition he deserves when
it comes to landing lead roles
in an interview with broadway world he
admitted that he's never had
job security in television and it's part
of the reason why he loves to switch
back and forth between screen and stage
performance
do you think jesse helped kevin's career
or just stereotyped him even more
point rhoda what
if the ice swan hasn't melted i can get
my money back
we may have all loved bertram but no one
was more in love with him
than mrs chesterfield or as people in
real life know her
carolyn hennessey just like kevin
chamberlain
carolyn has racked up a pretty
impressive resume yet she hasn't seemed
to open the door
into international fame working in
series like general hospital
the mindy project and suits she's been
nothing if not busy
landing a leading role has however
proved to be difficult for her
could this be because of her past with
disney according to her interview with
spectrum carolyn
literally grew up in disney both her
father and grandfather were in close
connection with walt himself
and were involved in the early
development of disney and disneyland
talk about a disney kid could that have
been the reason she landed her role on
jessie in the first place
this definitely could be networking at
its finest though it would be hard to
see
anyone feel the role of mrs chesterfield
like she did
you are the most amazing girl i have
ever met
pearson fo day on jessie was known as
brooks wentworth
mrs chesterfield's son and jessie's
eventual fiancee
if you don't remember things got pretty
awkward on screen
i don't did she just say i don't
well his role on jessie only really
kicked off towards the end of the series
his charming persona and acting
definitely took the show's last few
seasons to the next
level after leaving brooks behind
pearson went on to land a recurring role
in the hit soap opera
the bold and the beautiful and while he
has earned himself more than one emmy
nomination
it's really hard to say whether or not
he'll ever make it to the big screen and
international fame however the actor has
been super candid about his personal
life over the years
and has opened up about a health scare
that really put his life on hold
in an instagram post he let his almost
half a million followers know that he
suffered through some brain trauma that
could have been fatal
in his instagram post he shared a photo
that included a heart monitor
used for the doctors to track his
dangerous blackouts all we have to say
is we are so
glad he's okay what kind of director
would i be if i didn't expand your
comfort zone
well this next actress was unfortunately
never featured on jessie her character
definitely made a huge impact on the
ross family in their spin-off series
bunked
miranda may in fact continued to carry
literally the entire
show after payton karen and skye took
their leave
the show and miranda's role as the
hilarious camp counselor got so big
that they even had a crossover with the
reboot raven's home
the show recently came to an end after
its four season run and it looks like
miranda may be heading into the same
direction as the rest of the disney
stars
however she's admitted that being on
bunk actually fulfilled her dream goal
of becoming the lead of a comedy series
hopefully she can take her hilariousness
to another network one day
so happy ending i think it's safe to say
that after taking a deeper look into the
cast's lives there's just
no telling what the future holds from
surprise health scares to pursuing other
passions
there's no denying that despite their
lack of work they're still
all majorly talented awesome goku
what do you think the next step is for
these actors are you looking forward to
seeing what they do next
let us know in the comment section below
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up and hit that subscribe button if
you've been missing the jesse cast as
much as we have
catch you later